you
this video will help you understand
heart failure and how to manage it
please watch the entire video to learn
how to manage heart failure
if you've been diagnosed with heart
failure it's important to control your
symptoms heart failure also called
congestive heart failure or CHF is a
lifelong condition in which your heart
continues to work but not as well as it
should
your heart can't pump enough blood and
oxygen to meet the needs of your body
excess fluid builds up in the lungs legs
and other body tissues over time
heart failure weakens your heart and can
shorten your life
the symptoms of heart failure include
shortness of breath
chronic coughing or wheezing
swelling of the legs feet or abdomen
weight gain
feeling tired all the time nausea or
lack of appetite
heart palpitations
memory loss
and Confused thinking
fortunately you can help control your
symptoms by following your doctor's
instructions adopting a heart-healthy
lifestyle
and staying aware of changes in your
symptoms
following the instructions of your
health care team is very important in
managing your symptoms
this includes taking our medications
exactly as prescribed by your doctor
don't stop taking your medications or
skip doses
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
if the cost of your medication is an
issue discuss other options with your
doctor
don't take any over-the-counter
medication or supplement without asking
your doctor if it's okay
make and keep all of your follow-up
appointments for both doctor's visits
and lab tests
get vaccinated against the flu and
pneumonia as directed by your doctor
managing your heart failure also means
adopting a healthy lifestyle you may
need to make the following changes limit
your salt and sodium intake by doing the
following don't add salt when you cook
or to food at the table avoid processed
and fast foods compare food labels and
choose the items that are lower in salt
and sodium
eat a heart-healthy diet including
low-fat low-cholesterol
and high-fiber foods
a heart healthy diet helps you maintain
or achieve a good blood pressure and
weight
and helps prevent other conditions that
may further stress your heart
limit your alcohol intake ask your
doctor if your condition allows you to
include any alcohol in your diet
monitor your fluid intake from drinks
and foods that contain fluid too much
fluid makes your heart work harder
ask your doctor how much fluid is the
right amount for you
don't smoke nicotine increases heart
rate and blood pressure at the same time
as it decreases the amount of oxygen
rich blood delivered to your body's
tissues become physically active regular
exercise through daily activities such
as gardening and housework can make you
feel better
other good exercise options with your
doctor's approval are walking swimming
and bicycling as you exercise keep these
precautions in mind rest as needed stop
if you feel chest pain or more than
usual shortness of breath
and don't exercise when temperatures are
very hot or very cold
your doctor may also prescribe a cardiac
rehabilitation program that is a
combination of medically supervised
exercise lifestyle counseling and
education
it is important to stay aware of changes
in your symptoms and know when to get
help
using the traffic light colors green
yellow and red to assess how you feel
can help you take the proper action to
manage your heart failure symptoms
Green is your goal and means that your
symptoms are under control continue to
follow your doctor's directions and keep
all medical appointments
way yourself daily to see if your body
is retaining fluids do it at the same
time each day before eating or drinking
and we're the same type of clothing
record and take note of any changes in
your weight
symptoms in the yellow zone are warning
signs call your doctor immediately if
you gain three or more pounds in one day
or five pounds in one week
have an increased shortness of breath
have difficulty sleeping due to trouble
breathing feel persistent fast or
irregular heartbeats our feeling
lightheaded or as if you may faint
redzone symptoms are emergencies that
mean you need medical evaluation right
away call 911
chest pain that lasts more than 15
minutes severe and ongoing shortness of
breath coughing up pink frothy foam or
fainting
staying on top of your symptoms and
following your doctor's instructions can
help you manage heart failure